There's only one way to survive in the past Kill each other
and steal the candles It's a
different story, isn't it?
Please help
me I don't want to die
What are you doing
?  I wonder whose
candle it is that fell to the floor I
don't know for sure, but mine and Boruto's row are overlapping, so
I can't say which one it is.
The
candle is his candle
Maybe
everyone will be saved What is the director going to do
?
It
doesn't matter what kind of candle the ogre is
holding If you say that the candle he's holding is his candle
If
everyone holds a long candle that's tied together, the
rule prize is
everyone's candle It's
like that
I don't know if an idea can really help
me, but
I
don't want to kill
anyone here
You're a
[ __ ] bastard, but it looks like you're going to stick to the rules.